viendo pasar en este momento
y va con los restos funerarios de
algunos de los reyes
[Música]
según el sexo
todos ellos van a ser trasladados desde
el museo de antigüedades hasta el museo
del mistral quieren conseguir que
regrese el turismo
una buena imagen
y
todos estos
es un lugar donde la gente puede
aprender mejor y aprender más sobre lo
que es el antiguo
es muy importante para el que llevan
meses preparándose llevan dos horas
para ver
en cada uno de los coches va el nombre
del faraón que va adentro y vamos a ver
a continuación también el ajuar
funerario que lo acompañará es un
momento mágico es difícil describirlo la
música
realmente al ver como
realiza este trayecto en el siglo 21
algo que no podríamos haber imaginado